Hello, my name is Karl Deisseroth. I'm a
professor of bioengineering and psychiatry
at Stanford and the Howard Hughes Medical Institute.
And today, I'd like to tell you a little bit about
optogenetics. Some of the humble origins of this
method in science. Some of its applications
and some of the interesting lessons it teaches
us about the process of biology.
Now, I'm also a psychiatrist and a lot of the
inspiration for this technology came from psychiatry.
And although this is an important field in medicine,
it's got a long way to go. In many ways, we haven't progressed
too far in our basic description of the core symptoms
and their underpinnings, their causal underpinnings
than we had hundreds of years ago. Here
is a depiction of some of the earliest medical model
type descriptions of depression and its symptom
that today we call anhedonia, the inability to enjoy
normally rewarding things. And John Haslam
in the early 1800s described in melancholy,
what we would call depression today,
they therefore neglect those objects and pursuits
which formerly proved sources of delight and instruction.
And this is about as precise as we can be today about
what anhedonia really is in psychiatry.
And what's a really amazing part of this story is
microbial organisms, single celled forms of life,
have given us tools that in the last few years
have allowed us to come to a deeper understanding of
this fundamental and important medical and scientific
question. And many others like it. Now this
also gives an opportunity to take a broader view
about what is optogenetics, where does it stand
in the broader context of interventions and experiments
that we could do in neuroscience. And in the brain, which
as we all know, is a very complicated system with many
interconnecting parts, we have historically had the ability
to use either magnetic or electrical interventions to
stimulate neurons. But one problem is that they cannot
discriminate individual kinds of neurons that might be
right next to each other. They all look the same to an
electrical or a magnetic intervention. What optogenetics
allows us to do is to put a particular sensitizers -- antennas
of a sort, for external sources of energy and information
into specific kinds of neurons. And then we can use light,
in this case, if we make light sensitive antennas or
transducers, and make neurons of a particular kind respond
to light, and we do that to allow different kinds of ions
to flow into cells and turn neurons on or off depending on the
experiment. That's the fundamental idea of optogenetics
and it's something people have wanted to do for a very long
time. The first person who seemed to have framed the
possible solution to this age old question was Francis
Crick in 1999. He described the essence of this problem
that we needed to control, turn on or off individual
kinds of cells. And he suggested the ideal signal
would be light. He didn't have an idea how to do it
but in his usual perceptive fashion, he had some pretty
good instincts, I would say. And what I'd like to do here is
to sort of pay homage to the many people who've
thought about this and done experiments, and contributed
both historically and up to the present in making all of this
ultimately work. Now there were early efforts dating back
to 2002, a pioneer in this field, Gero Miesenboeck
was able to take individual components from a metazoan
eye, the multicellular organisms we all know of course,
we have light sensitive cells in our retinas. And they achieved
light sensitivity with a cascade of proteins, and he was able to
get to the point where he could bring some of those
individual components of that cascade together and
confer light sensitivity on neurons. And the bright areas
of this plot are where the light was on. And there were other
groups who also took what you might call a multicomponent
approach to try to make neurons light sensitive.
Now the only thing that held back these elegant methods
was in many ways their multicomponency which contributed
to difficulties in targeting, and they of course would be the first
state showed beautifully that some delay in the onset of
the responsivity, the action potentials that were fired
by the cells in response to the light. And what allowed
this field to take off was the microbial approach as I
alluded to earlier. Now these microbial organisms,
they're small, they don't have a lot of space to work with
and nor do they have to do as complex processing
as other organisms do. And so they had the leeway
evolutionarily, it seems, to make very efficient all in one
single component systems for both detecting light
and generating ion flow. And that allowed the generalizable
aspect of this solution to happen. And this is a field that
has its roots back, even as far back as the early 1970s.
Dieter Oesterhelt and Walter Stoeckenius in 1971
identified bacterial rhodopsin and over decades
they and a thriving community of researchers were able
to sort out how this amazing protein works, how it responds
to light, how its photocycle of the individual protein allows
ions to be transported across the membrane. And this
pump type class of opsins, bacteriorhodopsin being an example
is followed by the discovery of halorhodopsin,
where instead of protons being moved, chlorine ions
are moved instead. Peter Hegemann and his colleagues
beginning with some early predictive work in 1985
leading to a very important paper in 2002 showed
that there were also channel type microbial opsins that
opened actual pores in the membrane instead of pumping
one ion at a time. And then many groups, here
Feng Zhang in my laboratory was able to find a
red light activated channelrhodopsin in 2008.
And a great number of different groups, Feng Zhang,
Peter Hegemann, our colleague Ed Boyden, Georg Nagel,
Ernst Bamberg, John Spudich, and many others
have been identifying amazing, amazingly diverse
microbial opsins with different properties from across
the phylogenetic spectrum. Now, what is striking as
you'll notice from this, is how long we've known about
these and this happens to be my biochemistry textbook
The beautiful book written by Lubert Stryer in 1988,
this was the version that I used, and you can see this is
textbook type knowledge. Descriptions of the photocycle
of bacteriorhodopsin, for example. Part of the foundational
knowledge of biochemists and neurobiologists. Now there
were people who did try to put these microbial
opsins in different settings, in fact, successfully.
This is a very interesting paper from 1994, where
the bacteriorhodopsin was indeed transferred along with
light sensitive flow of ions into a eukaryotic organism.
But nobody had yet tried to actually create a tool for
neurobiology, to turn on or turn off individual kinds of
cells. Neurons are complicated, they're vulnerable,
they're sensitive, they're different but in principle,
it was an experiment that could be done. And there were
many people trying to do it. Now the path to this
in my own lab started very near to the time when I
had started setting up my independent laboratory.
And I had a very humble approach, where as you can see
I used very simple tallies to assess how the experiments
were working, and it's interesting to look back on the
simplicity of this early experiment. But what I was doing
here, I had a broader view in the lab to try different kinds
of proteins to see if we could turn neurons on or off
with different kinds of stimuli. I had acquired the channel
rhodopsin gene, I'd written to a group in Germany
that had worked on the initial clone from Georg Nagel
and he sent me the clone right away, which was very
generous of him. I was also looking at different kinds of
potassium channels, to see if we could turn on or off,
constitutively active or dominant negative potassium
channels. And I was putting all of these into separate groups of
neurons in culture to see if I could get control over their
activity level. And I was using a very simple straightforward
read out of membrane depolarization, the phosphorylation
of a transcription factor called Creb, which I had done
a lot of work on previously. And the amazing result was that
in these neurons, you can see by the red staining of the nucleus
of the cell in a stimulated compared to an unstimulated
neuron. Both of these were expressing the channel
rhodopsin coupled to a yellow fluorescent protein,
so I could see a number of things here. I could see
that the gene that I'd put in was being expressed,
it was being transported to the membrane, that the
neuron was healthy, it hadn't exploded as a result of
putting this high levels of this membrane protein into
the cell. Which can happen to be sure. And moreover
that the light activated, the light treated neuron revealed
that it had been stimulated. That its membrane had been
depolarized and calcium flux had occurred. And this
biochemical readout was telling us that this was happening.
And in neurons that were expression a lot of this channel
rhodopsin, I could see a big difference in the number
of cells that were reporting on this depolarization
event, and overall, this was statistically significant.
And although this was a very simple, cheap, humble
experiment, this showed us that it was possible.
And this was in early July of 2004, but things went
very quickly after that. This is what our small
group looked like at the time, you can see the two grad
students, Feng Zhang and Ed Boyden, now at MIT.
Feng Zhang now also very well known for his work on
CRISPR-Cas9 systems. But we knew that we had to do
a lot more than just show some neurons getting stimulated,
we had to show that this was unique, that it was
a potentially generalizable or versatile, that it could
potentially be applied in broader systems. And there was
rightly so a lot of skepticism at the time. What the students
did was some really brilliant and creative work. Feng Zhang
designed the viral systems that would allow us to put
the channel rhodopsin in a very versatile way into different
brain regions in vivo, and the fact that it's just a single gene
allowed us to be confident that this would work well.
Ed did a number of beautiful recordings, showing how fast
the process could be, which was another important feature
of the system. Both its potential generalizability and its
speed. And there were many other groups working on this
at the time, Stefan Herlitze, Zhuo-Hua Pan, Yawo's group
in Japan. But we were able to put the different pieces
together in time to get the paper out, and it was published
together with two students, Ed and Feng, as well as Georg
Nagel and Ernst Bamberg. And this, though, was, I
wouldn't even say this was yet a fully optogenetics because
there was a great deal more work that needed to happen.
It took about five more years of very intense effort to
show that we had actually created something that was
generalizable, useful, and broadly applicable, which was
the key goal. So optogenetics didn't start overnight,
experiments were humble and simple, but it took a number
of years to actually say that we finally discovered how to
make this work. Part of the problem was how do you get
light into big mammalian brains. And this was an early
sketch of Feng Zhang's, where he designed the fiber optic
interface. And this was from 2006, but then this looks very
much like how we now do it today. So as you can see
he's a good artist and a great scientist. And this
fiber optic interface has since allowed us to do many
things, but I'll show you one other first experiment.
This was two years later in 2007, Feng was working
with some mice that we had made in collaboration with
Guoping Feng and George Augustine, and these
were mice designed to have channelrhodopsin
expressed in the brain and what Feng did was he implanted
into this mouse, a fiber optic on the right side of its
brain, which as you know would control movement
toward or attention to the left side of the world. And
when he turned on the light, as you can see here
the animal immediately starts moving, starts turning
to the left. And this was the moment I would say
we finally knew we had made something that was going to be
broadly applicable and generalizable. And that was followed
quickly by a collaborative set of experiments with
Luis de Lecea, Alex Aravanis, Antoine Adamantidis,
and others, where we applied this fiber optic interface
to target a deep structure in the brain, in lateral
hypothalamus. Feng designed some promoters
that would fit into a lentivirus and allow us to control
just one kind of cell deep in the hypothalamus.
And with this work, we were able to play in certain kinds
of activity and show some of the neural codes that were
causal in sleep-wake transitions. And then, even then though
this required some very specific fragment of a promoter,
the hypocretin promoter, which would fit into a virus.
And there was still greatly so some skepticism as to how
broadly generalizable this would be. But between 2009
and 2010, we finally were able to show that there were
a broad array of different tools you could use to
generalizably target different kinds of cells. And by this
point, I would say by 2010 or so, people were able
to see that this could be applied to virtually any system.
A good example of how that all worked was in our
studies in anxiety. Now anxiety is a normal part of
life, it's a healthy part of life, of course it can become
excessive and it can be pathological in some cases.
But what we were able to do is to use optogenetics
to play in patterns of activity or suppress patterns
of activity in particular cells or projections in and around
structures relating to the basolateral amygdala,
and the bed nucleus of the stria terminalis.
And the way we did some of these experiments is we
injected a virus, an adeno associated viral vector into
the structure of interest, the GNST, but then we were able
to position our fiber optics in other downstream structures.
By doing so, we were able to recruit cells to find by having
a particular projection pattern, which as you can see
is a generalizable strategy. You don't need a special
kind of animal or a special promoter, you just need to know
your anatomy. And this works because the opsins are
trafficked down the axons of the cells, particularly if we
help them out with little trafficking motifs that were
discovered in the lab by Viviana Gradinaru and her
colleagues. And I'll show you an example of how
this sort of thing works. This is an experiment,
I'll play this movie, Kay Tye in the lab's work which
was published in 2011. This is a what's called an elevated
plus maze, this so-called closed arm has these elevated
walls and you'll see that the animal prefers to spend its
time in the closed arm of the maze. Very rarely venturing
out into the open arms of the maze, which is like walking
the plank for the animal. Both in our studies of anxiety
related behaviors, what we found and what Kay was
able to show, and we followed this up with a great deal
of other work, was that there were anti-anxiety
pathways buried within the brain. When the blue letters
come on here, you'll see when she started driving one
of these, as we discovered, anti-anxiety pathways.
And you'll see for the first time, the mouse is willing
to go out into the open arms and explore, which it
never had done before. Nothing else changed
about the animal, the speed or anything else,
it simply was willing to accept this risk. And this was
instantaneously reversible and this of course was only
one feature of anxiety, apprehension in the absence
of immediate threat. But there are other features, too.
Respiratory rate changes, subjective feeling,
anxiety feels bad and resolution of anxiety feels good.
And in later work, we were able to show different
projections coming from the bed nucleus of the stria
terminalis recruit different features of anxiety using
this projection targeting approach, where we position
the fiber optic in a different location than the injection
of the virus. And this sort of thing allowed the
generalizability of optogenetics to become clear.
And so, in this sort of work, if you think back to
those very early humble experiments in culture,
you can see it took a number of years to finally put
all the pieces together. I'm often asked what's the
potential clinical impact of optogenetics, and although
I'm a psychiatrist, I run a purely basic science laboratory.
I'm not working on clinical translation in my lab.
But it's a natural question to ask, and other people
are working on it. The group of Antonello Bonci
found in 2013 that they could turn down cocaine seeking
behavior in rats with optogenetic stimulation of the
medial prefrontal cortex. A very striking result that
they published in 2013. And that was then followed up
with Antonello Bonci and some clinical colleagues with
a optogenetically guided clinical intervention.
They used transcranial magnetic stimulation, which can
be non-invasively delivered to awake human beings.
Of course, human brains are a lot bigger but they have
a lot of the same basic reward circuitry and what they found
was guided by optogenetics, they were able to
have a group of cocaine addicted human beings
no longer seek cocaine. They had an experimental group and
a control group, and they had a very powerful effect.
This sort of thing shows how far we've come,
that we can directly affect with a principle-guided
approach, these very powerful and important fundamental
behaviors in human beings. And this makes, of course
coming back to the initial inspiration that we have
starting to go down this path, now we do understand
in a causal and precise fashion many of the cells
and connections across the brain that do affect
these very important and both basic and disease
relevant behaviors. Now this, of course, had very humble
beginnings, as you recall, those initial tallies in the lab
notebook. And we've come a long way since then.
But in a way, it's even more striking when you think
how these very simple organisms themselves
have created these tools that let us make this
progress. There's a whole other world that has
happened as well, in terms of discovering how these
basic microbial opsins work. We've been able
to adjust the speed of the opsins. Their sensitivity to light.
We've been able to engineer them to conduct
different kinds of ions to turn cells on or off.
Guided by getting to the crystal structure of
one of these channel rhodopsins. And we can change
the color that they respond to, as well.
This has allowed us to do something very important
which is to tune the amount and the timing of the activity
that we play into precisely what's naturally occurring
in the organism, even that same individual during a very
well-defined behavior. And so this elegance and precision
of the method is all the more striking when you think back
to how crude some of the early experiments were.
And how long it took to get the whole system working.
But in the end, that's what makes biology fun
and beautiful. And I hope to have conveyed some of that
to you today.